when everybody's walked in the kitchen -
nice and you saw this he goes always a
molecular cook em home canister it's
kind of a revelation even though we take
it for granted now that we can create
something like whipped cream out of a
material that doesn't have all those
components know by note cooking is
something that that grows out of and
extends on molecular gastronomy and
takes it a step further because it's
really based on using compounds to
create food if you have beef and meat
you make beefing and meat if you have a
cat and fish you put carrot on fish and
that's all but if you have a the sea
under the compounds of carrots and the
300 compounds of fish you make 90
thousand combinations which means that
in front of us who is not by not cooking
we have a huge new continent which is
like America compared to the old world
one of the questions I often ask myself
is just what can be water you know if we
were to take an egg white which is water
and protein take the water away and then
rehydrate that protein with something
else a beet juice we have a beet
meringue I'm making a soft caramel and
there's water and soft caramel I thought
why not replace that with carrot juice
you know from you go on and on and on
creating new things in a familiar
context how they is really pushing a new
frontier new boundaries and thinking
about cooking we've had a lot of
molecular cuisine in New York and Spain
and France over the last 10 or 15 years
but it's mostly been sort of decorative
new ways of thinking about presenting
old styles of cooking and this goes
right to the heart of it breaking
ingredients down and breaking
preparations down is simply a way to bed
understand them and a way to become a
better cook and to make things taste
better as a pastry chef I have to be
able to predict the future when I cook
so understanding the component parts of
everything and how they work and how
they function is really what I do so
adopting this idea of note by note
cuisine is is feels natural it's really
an attempt to bring a modernist
revolution to food of the kind that
you've had already in the past hundred
years and architecture and music art to
rethink food in a very fundamental way
instead of just rethinking it in
superficial ways in France and America
about half of food produced is spoiled
which means that if you can avoid the
spoilage you can multiplies the food
production by to Elvis season open up
cooking is an important way to think
about how we can feed a growing world
population how we can process and move
foods around more efficiently to be able
to feed more people so it really has an
interest for people concerned about
population growth and sustainability and
how our understanding of food and
processing of food has to change in
response to those growing pressures I
think as a this particular event is
funny because it tells us a lot of what
could be done in the future yeah that's
why we need people like you
mmm to push us in the right direction